i feel like i'm learning a lot on this
job
it's um very different than acting on a
film
that's a much more insular process
it's important how you work with others
but
this i feel like i'm constantly learning
from other people
do you feel like you learn from all the
human beings you interact with on your
show
on your multiple shows yeah i think
that's just a human thing that's uh
some something that you uh which which
especially for someone like myself
i'm i'm basically in real life when i'm
clark kent
i'm i'm pretty much an introvert i have
always been since i was a kid it's just
just i like my own company
um but
the beautiful thing about whatever set
you're on
whether it's a tv show or whether it's
the game show
you do get a chance to learn and i think
as an
actor or as a host or as just someone in
entertainment you should always
strive to learn on a daily basis
just as a human you you should strive to
learn but but
even just for our job i learn from
people
every single day whether it's learning a
character trait
learning a cool new accent from somebody
that
that i met met in a meeting or watching
be really cool to somebody else so i can
go oh
that's that's empathy at work so i can
put that into use later on
or learning a cool fact that i can put
into
my improvisation where i'm where i need
a bit of
useless knowledge that just pops to the
forefront and working on a game show
really really helps because you meet
people from
all over the world all different races
creeds and and it makes you you uh
it it stocks up your your stores of
knowledge
now another thing i feel like i could
you know pick your brain about
is co-parenting which you've been so
kind to include us in your life
and for those of us out here who are in
a co-parenting dynamic
the harmony that you and your
daughter miley and you know her mom have
is just so aspirational what is
a good secret out there maybe for people
to know
to have that kind of harmony in their
own co-parenting dynamics
drew um i wish i could tell you
it's secret if that were the case i
would have sold 15 million books already
i would have brought them right yeah but
tell you when it comes to our situation
i would say work and it sounds like such
a small thing it's like
work but but what's pretty cool is
that's my baby mama right there
and that's her boyfriend jason and
that's my daughter miley
when people look at our tick tocks right
they see
the picture of harmony and co-parenting
and making a blended family that you
want
we just sold a sitcom to cbs based on
our fam
family because people started seeing our
family during the pandemic and went oh
my god that's so weird
here's the thing and this is the thing
that i even tell my writing partners
when working on the sitcom you see that
tick tock
and folks online go oh my god it's so
aspirational what's your secret
if you would have seen the five minutes
before that tick tock
good the work it takes to get to that
tick tock
just in life the the yelling
the the screaming the fun the tears the
ups the downs
the not being able to talk to each other
for a week because you can't see eye to
eye
you you are trying to make another
person happy while caring for this
little
person you want to strangle each other
sometimes
that those tick tocks would not be
possible if we had not
worked for me to be able to love
mandy the way that i do and she loves me
and she has my back and we care about
nothing more than the well-being of this
daughter
and then for me to consider jason a part
of my family
the work that that took that's not for
everybody
because i don't think that everybody has
that love
for the other person you should
but i don't know if everyone can do it
but if you can
the beautiful thing is you have a family
that you made
and you have a child who has two parents
that
show their love because they love you so
that's my soapbox
i i love it and i'm just such an
advocate
for keeping that love and respect
and a lack of tension away
from your kids so i just loved that
really quickly i know your daughter's
about to turn 18
and thanks to tick-tock and things like
that
what did you say to your daughter you
know when she said i want to go out
and you know take a risk and put myself
out there i said go for it
and um the the one piece of advice that
i gave her
is don't do it to be famous that's my
problem with tick-tock and social media
um and and and i sound like old man
brady shaking my fist
on on on my lawn but
instead of looking at it going oh i
can't wait till i blow up
and i want followers be good first
if you're gonna sing if you're gonna
dance if you're gonna act be really
great at it
and i really do believe that if you're
great at something
if you become an outlier the other stuff
will come to you
so that's the only word of advice that
i've given her and she's taken it
and she's run with it and she's she's
going to be fine all on her own
well i know she's going to be fine
because
listening to everything you say is
so salient so wise so
sage i think you need to
father us all wayne or you know brother
or
shepherd i don't know but i preach
speak everything you're saying i'm like
absolutely i'm hanging on your every
word
really and truly um it is such a
pleasure to get to know you
thank you thanks drew and watch let's
make a deal because you already
are on cbs you check your local listings
thanks wayne